[Applause]
well it is Thanksgiving week and we are
always thankful when our first guest
stops by that's why we're calling this
whole hour gratitude with
G he is the only artist in music history
to have nine albums to be certified
diamond which means they each hold over
10 million units just in case you're
wondering at home most artists have like
one album that might sell that much and
he's got nine uh his latest album is
called time traveler it's available as
part of the limited series 7even dis box
set you can find it exclusively at a
Bass Pro Shop near you don't man if you
go there you're G to end up with 50,000
things you didn't know you want it's
like Target it's a but it's a great
store but you end up with everything and
you're like I'm totally going to go
fishing um Everybody give it up for gar
[Applause]
Brooks
[Music]
[Applause]
I trying to
be oh I was like I was waiting for
you and I thought you waiting so good so
good
but Happy Thanksgiving by the way thank
you very much I'm going to put my gut
Hider on I love it thank you very
much now I can relax now it's now it's
out I love you right now um well wait
this is all this is we're it's like
we're related um so wait what today is
all about gratitude which I think is
perfect for you we were trying to find
because we love you on this show we've
had you on we're like what can we do
that's like different and special and
Thanksgiving was this week and you're
such a gift giving person but I think
that you're also always in a state of
like gratitude for everything as well
which is cool because you recognize all
the blessings yeah amen that same way I
am but you're like the next degree we've
talked about this me and my friends yeah
I everybody thought I was like this and
then they you were introduced in their
life and they're like oh no you don't
even count um but what does this what
does it mean to like be grateful
especially around Thanksgiving like what
do you do you go big for Thanksgiving
your family yeah well when you're
married to well one of the greatest
Cooks on the planet oh my God don't brag
about it no I won't I won't we'll talk
about how great of a singer she is next
and then we'll talk about that that's
probably five and six on her list of top
10 things to do um but she uh I think
it's fun my thing is this and you guys
might feel the same way when it comes to
the future you know I think it's what
you're just grateful for is just one
more day right of getting to do this so
I think that's it just truthfully if I
could say what I'd love to say is uh the
day I take my last breath on this planet
i' love for my three girls to be around
me and I love for the Queen to be around
me but uh as far as Miss Yearwood um I
don't know you know I've said this
before I found her in the past life I'll
find her in the next she just it's just
I love well have a great day
everybody she makes it fun you know yeah
no she makes it really cry at lunch G
okay um so it is amazing though it's
such a beautiful love between the two of
you it is and you're tearing up and
you're making me tear up and my makeup
artist is going to kill me not tearing
up so yeah you are yeah you are I love
it it so wait so um why time traveler
why the title of that well you know
country music is well if not better than
everybody and country music just stays
sincere it does its thing but through
the decades sometimes it gets dressed up
different yeah and I swear you could
take two of these cuts and you can play
them in the 70s they would fit you could
take a couple of these Cuts it' be in
the 90s I mean that's kind of where you
know the where our stuff was born and
then the stuff that'll just go right
along with today's stuff so that's what
I love about country music as much as
you might dress it different through the
decades it still stays true to itself
and so time traveler just seemed to pass
through all those eras of country music
yeah it's a cool title well in
celebration of Thanksgiving this week we
are doing a little gratitude with GTH
[Applause]
y'all grateful for where you came from
right this is like something that you
always talk about right amen yeah it's
it's you're grateful for where you're
from and you're grateful that you kind
of ended up where you're at you know if
that makes any sense and people go hey
would you change anything in the past
you go not if it would change one thing
of where I'm at right now right that's
the
thing yeah even the bad stuff even the
stuff that's not great is the bad stuff
bad I mean here's the thing so sometimes
so we talk about marriage sometimes and
sometimes marriage doesn't work out but
the children you have oh they're the
perfect mix of whoever you and maybe you
didn't get along with them but those
kids would have to be different if you
just love them the way they are it's
well sometimes the way they are but you
know what I mean no wait okay so explain
this is the third limited series set
right so explain why and why Bass Pro
Shop I love Bass Pro Shop but man you go
in that place it's like Target you go
out with things you don't need but you
love yeah well you don't know you need
them yet do you oh you'll get there okay
right she not enough time but why why
why this well well it's really cool so
before you were born we did the first
limited series right no so in the 9s we
did a limited series and then uh in 2008
we did a second limited series and now
this is our last one and what it does is
allows you to catch up on the past music
without having to pay for all of them so
you kind of do hopefully a small price
for this perfect for Christmas like a
bundle kind of stuff a bundle is a
beautiful word yeah so it's um it's cool
and Bass Pro is our partner you usually
do it through big box retail yeah uh and
they're one of three of the big boxes
out there but the other two uh big box
retailers just their music section just
keeps shrinking shrinking shrinking down
and this one we got to help Johnny
Morris and Ducks Unlimited to work on uh
conservation of wildlife with this box
set so it's a cool marriage so that's
why we're here together beautiful well I
love that do you listen to your old St
are you always you do oh my God I love
me I love you're like look at this Jam I
did in
91 I can't believe I just said that me
and you I'm getting way too comfortable
no you know why though it's actually
very beautiful because I there are
sometimes I will say this it's only
because of the performance there's some
things I look back on I'm like I good on
that one like I get and I get proud and
I do listen to it I am a lot of my
listens on YouTube because sometimes you
do get really proud of certain things
you do and oh my god when we were kids
in Oklahoma and Texas it was our Dream
to get to accomplish this so it's like
you don't want to take advantage you
know of of that and just like really
recognize the blessing so I get that
yeah maybe guys are luckier than girls
because girls are always harder on
themselves of course but guys keep it
kind of conversational right so you can
listen to the old stuff and the old
stuff isn't singing as much as just tell
me the story so so how was this
residency cuz I went to the last one
this one was different you did a
different thing how how has it been so
you know Caesars the the stage is pretty
wide it's pretty wide for a Onan show no
matter how much ground of cover it's
it's still wide kind of thing so what we
do is we put dinner tables out hung
chandeliers love and people are sitting
at those dinner tables but the people
sitting at the dinner tables are the
band oh I love that so if you want to
play George Straits Amarillo by Morning
then Jimmy mingle just picks up his
fiddle comes over and plays with you and
goes back sits down they're drinking all
night at the end of night you'll see but
uh something in the whole comes up when
we play friends or calling that Rouge
some of that stuff so it's fun do you
need to change it up like that yeah
because we got through with the stadium
run say how do you make it bigger than
the stadium run it's easy you guys know
this flip it on its head where it's just
me and you and the music intimacy that's
when it gets big right so cool and yeah
here's the cool thing that people are
kind of a little bit odd about at first
yeah we bag the phones oh yeah yeah yeah
so you bag the phone so you go in there
so we've had people uh come in and and
you get emails and letters and and
little sweet notes ago we came in and we
sat down and some people sat down we
didn't know and you know what we did we
started talking to them oh my gosh I was
like are you kidding me and they then
they exchanged numbers they became best
buddies they sang the same songs
together but didn't know each other
before that night to me that's what
music is music is the voice of gathering
right he 100% music makes I don't know
music makes good of everything but I
also think it's the voice of hope for us
to end up being together
as a as a whole unit I love music and
what me too I heard that you were
playing new stuff yeah like on this
album you were playing that at the Vegas
shows yeah so which is so special for
fans when you bag the phones then you
can try new stuff on them right and they
don't know that they're coming in and
thinking they're going to have a good
time oh God it's Amateur hour here we go
and you play them something that they've
never heard and I'm telling you it's
like a Polaroid it's instant you get you
get the instant you suck or holy cow
kind of thing right I'm into that or
like oh oh should I go to the bathroom
um all right well tell me about this
song it's St Paul Minneapolis right yeah
you did that one in Vegas right yeah and
in parenthesis it says a true story oh I
love it so this really happened to me I
mean tell me about the story so you ran
into someone yeah and you can't tell
much because I really want this person
to tell me so this person knows
everything um but I got to tell you
there was something just really me and
Miss Sherwood we talk about it we take
walks and and there was something so
easy about the conversation
it was crazy so i' like I'd just like to
find this person again to see if if it
was something that's always that way and
if it is I want to know why something
they do or is it just a I have no idea
it's you know those things you can't
control those feelings that come over
you but uh I would love to see if I
could find this person and and just uh
become friends she was uh she was a she
was a great help and a great uh period
of time and didn't didn't ask for
anything or seemed to assume anything in
return oh my gosh that's good I want to
find this
person cuz I want the whole
story all right well let's take a quick
break and grab some tissues um the gar
Brooks plus one residency returns to the
Coliseum at Caesar's Palace starting
November 29th go online for ticket
[Music]
information
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home